point d'orgue des cérémonies du
débarquement 22 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement aux commémorations
d'arromanches hommage et ovations
vétéran dans les airs la patrouille de
france dans tous les coeurs la gratitude
aux soldats de la liberté et le devoir
de transmettre cet héritage moment
historique avec la participation pour la
première fois d'un dirigeant allemand la
première célébration commune
franco-allemande du débarquement
gerhard schröder appel à rendre pour
toujours la guerre impossible en europe
la disparition de ronald reagan à l'âge
de 93 ans l'amérique est en deuil offrir
à des funérailles nationales à celui qui
fut d'abord acteur avant d'entrer en
politique
le 40ème président des états unis était
particulièrement populaires et puis
l'incroyable finale à roland garros avec
la victoire tout à fait inattendue de
gaston gaudio qui a battu son
compatriote argentin guillermo coria 5,7
madame monsieur bonsoir les
commémorations du débarquement sont à
peine achevée et chacun ressent
l'exceptionnelle dimension de ce 60e
anniversaire de la libération
d'abord parce qu'il n'y a jamais eu
autant de vétérans dernier témoin pour
assister aux cérémonies jamais non plus
un chef d'état russe et un chant ciel
également n'avait participé à cette
communion du souvenir enfin parce que ce
rendez vous était celui de la
réconciliation
1re manche pendant près de deux heures
22 chefs d'état et de gouvernement se
sont inclinés devant le courage de ceux
qui nous ont apporté la liberté va
swinguer il ne marche plus bien ou pas
ne se tiennent plus très droit qu'un
plan il force le respect et de vente eux
les plus grands s'incline ou plutôt non
il se lève
et applaudissent
il y à la 22 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais les vraies vedettes ce
sont eux les vétérans de la libération
le protocole n'avait sûrement pas prévu
cela la musique s'arrête mais l'ovation
continue
les mains ne peuvent s'arrêter de battre
et sur les visages des deux hommes on
lit la fierté et l'émotion
ils sont des centaines et pour le
symbole c'est à 14 d'entre eux qu'on
remet la légion d'honneur
la phrase est toujours la même mais les
noms ne se ressemblent pas en seize
officiers de la légion d'honneur
ils viennent de 14 pays différents
francis dans la france la guerre était
mondiale et le courage internationale
ils venaient du canada d'australie de
nouvelle zélande
ils venaient du luxembourg de belgique
des pays-bas de norvège de grèce ils
étaient polonais tchèques slovaques il
était jeune
plein d'audace portés par le même élan
un même idéal un même amour de leur
patrie et cette conviction profonde de
la justesse de leur combat qui par delà
la peur les faisait consentir aux
suprêmes sacrifices mesdames et
messieurs ont ce jour anniversaire
le monde entier nous regarde
ils voient des peuples libres qui honore
les plus grands de leur héros ils voient
des peuples fidèles qui se souviennent
des sacrifices consentis il voit des
peuples réconcilier qui oeuvrent pour la
paix les grands de ce monde acquiesce
george bush tony blair mais aussi pour
la première fois vladimir poutine et
gerhard schröder
dans son discours le président français
a dit qu'il n'y avait pas d'avenir sans
mémoire
en couvrant de fleurs aujourd'hui les
survivants du jour j la france et ses
amis leur ont promis de ne pas oublier
leurs sacrifices et de s'en montrer
digne
puis ce sont les années noires qui ont
défilé sur écrans géants face à la mer
une évocation d'une grande intensité
avec pour message transmettre aux
générations futures le souvenir de ceux
qui sont tombés au combat et le sens de
l'engagement et de la démocratie
alban nicosie
le chant des marais composé en 1933 par
les prisonniers des premiers camps de
détention des allemands arrêtés par les
ss
ils illustrent les ténèbres nazis mais
aussi les premières résistances
oh
pendant près d'une heure vétérans et
personnalités ont pu suivre une
émouvante évocation de la deuxième
guerre mondiale du fracas du
débarquement des souffrances infligées
aux civils et aux soldats toutes
nationalités confondues jusqu'à la
délivrance de la libération est liée à
la joie des populations
sylvain l'occasion aussi de rendre
hommage à ceux qui ne sont plus là
célèbre joue inconnu c'est sans doute à
ce que pensait ces centaines de vétérans
très ému pendant toute la cérémonie
la normandie n'oublie pas sa liberté ni
sa part de souffrance
non mais chavire et a été certes
présents au premier rang mais ceux qui
furent célébrées cet après midi c'était
ses hommes désormais âgé pour qui ce
jour est comme un dernier pèlerinage sur
les lieux de leurs actes de bravoure
c'est à eux que s'adresse message tout
simple de la normandie et au delà de la
france tout entière
merci
voyons maintenant comment la cérémonie
d'arromanches a été vécu par ceux qui
n'étaient pas dans les tribunes le
périmètre des cérémonies étaient
inaccessibles mais c'était la télévision
en levant les yeux au ciel pour voir la
patrouille de france que des milliers de
spectateurs ont participé à leur façon à
cet anniversaire julia delage
j'ai eu du repos au 23 chefs d'état et
de gouvernement les auteurs
d'arromanches pour les milliers de
spectateurs en bas de la falaise vue
imprenable sur le dispositif de sécurité
pour suivre la cérémonie internationale
un écran géant
mais là encore problème j'avais essayé
de monter au site officiel j'ai bougé si
la foule privé d'oreilles n'a pas
entendu les discours officiels
elle s'est au moins régaler les yeux
mais la haute voltige ne remplace pas un
président alors on attend
depuis 3 heures 15 normalement on aurait
dit avoir deux présidents qui devrait
être là est en fin de contrat mais n'est
pas là on se fait attendre en cuir après
quelques rafraîchissements la foulée de
nouveaux attaque et accueille comme il
se doit la centaine de vétérans
britanniques invité par l'as rome
beaucoup sont venus pour eux par respect
une reconnaissance dans l attente
on sait aussi la prendre avec
philosophie là pour ça et ils sont très
contents
il a heureusement encore les anglais
parlent ou non on n'arrive pas à
comprendre et on ne va plus chez tout le
temps il est très très bien me sens très
content et très heureux
certains sont sur place depuis 10 heures
ce matin
l'attenté fut longue alors le plaisir
n'en est que plus grand des forums
impressionnant arrivée triomphale en une
heure à peine la reine a clos la journée
en bleu et ont beaucoup sur les plages
de normandie se sentent dit cette
cérémonie qui se sont succédé avec ce
matin pour commémorer le jour le plus
long
george bush et jacques chirac au
cimetière de colleville qui surplombe la
plage d'omaha la sanglante devant des
très nombreux vétérans vibrant hommage
de la france qui n'oublie pas florence
bocchia les etats-unis et la france côte
à côte
unis par un même devoir de mémoire au
cimetière américain de colleville george
bush jacques chirac honorer ce matin
ceux qui se sont sacrifiés pour libérer
l'europe face à omaha beach
avec ses 9 1386 croix blanche
le cimetière de colleville et la plus
grande nécropole des alliés en normandie
face aux croix un mémorial sur son socle
c'est mou de mes yeux j'ai vu arriver la
doire divine est un vétéran de 21 coups
de canon
puis c'est la sonnerie aux morts
et le discours ému du chef de l'état
français à toute la nation américaine
qui partage avec nous ses instants de
recueillement à ces femmes et à ces
zones qui ont payé le lourd tribut de
ces journées héroïque
je veux exprimer le message de la france
celui de l'amitié et de la fraternité
celui de la reconnaissance et de la
gratitude à son tour george bush hommage
aux troupes des alliés du 6 juin 44
les nations qui ont libéré l'europe
asservie allaient s'unir pour la liberté
de l'europe toute entière
les nations qui se sont battus sur ce
continent allait devenir des alliés pour
la cause de la paix cette grande
alliance pour la liberté est solide et
le v6 tdi est toujours nécessaire
aujourd'hui l'amérique honore tous les
libérateurs qui ont combattu ici qu'ont
les causes les plus nobles et l'amérique
referais la même chose quand ses amis
la foule est ému soyeuse au milieu des
poignées de main et des accolades tom
hanks et steven spielberg
acteur et réalisateur d'un film culte
sur le débarquement il faut sauver le
soldat ryan
autre temps fort que l'histoire
retiendra la première participation de
l'allemagne aux commémorations du
débarquement
gerhard schröder s'est d'abord recueilli
au cimetière de ranville où sont
enterrés soldats allemands et alliés
il a déposé une couronne de fleurs en
leur mémoire puis s'est incliné devant
la tombe d'un soldat anonyme
la présence du chancelier allemand est
un symbole salué par les européens et
les américains
une page est donc tournée le
débarquement comme l'a dit gerhard
schröder était aussi une libération pour
l'allemagne bertrand cocq
ce devait être l'un des événements de la
journée la soirée déjà presque entamée
lorsque jacques chirac accueille le
chancelier allemand gerhard schröder au
mémorial de caen
après les hymnes les deux hommes passent
en revue de compagnie de la brigade
franco allemande avant de s'offrir un
bain de foule
300 jeunes collégiens français et
allemands sont les invités de cette
cérémonie hautement symbolique
puis jacques chirac et gerhard schröder
fait naître seul à l'intérieur du
mémorial afin d'y dévoiler une plaque
fraudeurs qui n'avait que deux mois lors
du débarquement et la première homme
d'état allemand invité aux
commémorations du jour j
un geste qu'a voulu jacques chirac
consacrant ainsi la réconciliation
franco allemande
cette cérémonie témoigne devant le monde
qu'il n'aime par deux conflits futile
douloureux et profond qui ne put seul
jour laisser place au dialogue et à
l'entente aux hommes qui s'affrontent
dans la nuit interminable de la haine et
du ressentiment notre réconciliation
offre une véritable espérance
les françaises et les français vous
recevoir plus que j'allais en ami billy
brosnan
cette journée du 6 juin 2004 signe donc
la réconciliation franco-allemande à
caen ville martyre les habitants sont
satisfaits comme le montre ce reportage
de bernard lebras nicolas le marine et
jean-françois mais ils se sont fait
attendre mais les inviter le public
était au rendez vous afin de vivre ce
moment historique
quand capitale normande se voulait ce
soir loin des commémorations la capitale
de l'avenir européen et donc de la
réconciliation
il porte l'uniforme de la bundeswehr
l'actuelle armée allemande et ils ont la
charge d'accueillir les anciens de la
wehrmacht
ces vétérans qui ont combattu ici en
normandie interdit de cérémonie
d'arromanches
mais rassembler à caen au premier rang
parmi eux
hans grugger le mitrailleur allemand
d'omaha beach
les mesures de sécurité sont à la taille
de l'événement et saufs les invités
triés sur le volet au premier rang le
public lui étaient tenus à distance
derrière des barrières
même si très logiquement ceux qui sont
venus soutiennent la présence allemand
foccart des souvenirs mais faut
maintenant vive faut faire l'europe et
le remplacera l'allemagne je crois que
c'est sur le meilleur allié non c'est
très très bien ce que tu reviens normal
parce qu'ils ont participé à la guerre
donc
même si c'est de l'autre côté peut-être
pas concilier c'est une force aussi ça
signe de paix la volonté affichée et
très pédagogique et les jeunes ont été
vos noms qui est convié à cette
cérémonie historique voulu par cet homme
l'ancien maire de caen aujourd'hui cette
réconciliation est consacrée
officiellement à caen dans le mémorial
qui a été en partie
bien sûr on a demandé pour symboliser
cette réconciliation à la brigade
franco-allemande d'être présente à caen
caen ex villes martyres qui veut croire
d'autant plus en la construction de
l'europe
partons maintenant pour bayer ou la
reine elizabeth et jacques chirac ont
remonté l'allée centrale du plus grand
cimetière britannique où reposent près
de 5000 soldats
une cérémonie religieuse s'est ensuite
déroulée en présence de milliers de
vétérans britanniques
rappelons que la reine avait 18 ans au
moment du débarquement et que retenir de
cette journée si riche en symboles en
images en émotions peut-être d'abord
cette vision d'omaha beach à l'aube tout
comme il ya 60 ans emmanuel lambert le
soleil se lève sur omaha beach
il ya 60 ans les seuls rayons étincelant
jaillissaient des mitrailleuses
c'est sur cette plage que le
débarquement fut le plus meurtrier ce
matin dit rassemblement improvisé à la
mémoire des soldats tombés au combat
ils revivent le jour j
autre plage autres débarquement la foule
se presse à gold beach à l'est
d'arromanches le 6 juin 44 25 mille
britannique déferlent sur le sable arme
au poing dans les barges aujourd'hui les
jeunes soldats sont accueillis sous le
feu nourri du soleil j'espère seulement
que ces gars là n'auront jamais à le
faire pour de vrai quelques pas pour
revivre l'un des tournants de l'histoire
vétérans soldats ou simples citoyens
unis dans un même pèlerinage certains
repartiront même avec ce sable sacré
en tenue d'époque ces soldats d'un jour
graver à jamais sur les plages de
normandie la mémoire de tous ceux qui
sont morts au nom de la liberté et nous
vous retrouvons daniel bilalian
directeur ouistreham pour une page
spéciale dans quelques instants
oui effectivement béatrice nos reporters
l'ont bien montré après la liesse
populaire du début du week-end l'émotion
est montée d'un cran aujourd'hui avec
les différentes cérémonies dont nous
avons rendu compte
et puis cette réunion entre jacques
chirac et le chancelier allemand gerhard
schröder qui montre la réconciliation
soixante ans après le 6 juin 1944
cette émotion nous allons continuer donc
à en rendre compte dans quelques
instants
merci daniel coïncidence de l'histoire
un autre président américain ronald
reagan avait lui aussi participé il ya
20 ans aux commémorations du
débarquement ronald reagan 40e président
des états unis s'est éteint à l'âge de
93 ans essai de normandie que george
bush a salué sa mémoire une écoute en ya
20 ans un autre président américain est
venu ici en normandie pour rendre
hommage aux hommes du jour j était
lui-même un homme courageux et vaillants
défenseurs de la liberté
aujourd'hui nous honorons la mémoire de
ronald reagan
atteint de la maladie d'alzheimer depuis
plus de dix ans ronald reagan s'est donc
éteint hier l'amérique est en deuil
l'ancien président américain avait une
très forte popularité des funérailles
nationales se dérouleront la semaine
prochaine avant cela sa dépouille
reposera au capitole ronald reagan à la
tête de la maison blanche durant deux
mandats consécutifs aura marqué ces
années par la guerre des étoiles et la
fin de la guerre froide
alan shearer lorsque ronald réel très
fièrement ce mois de janvier 80
l'amérique ne se rend pas compte qu'elle
a changé d'ère en élisant un acteur il
est entré dans l'ère de la communication
le nouveau président est d'abord celui
qui saura huit ans durant et comme
personne auparavant parlé à son peuple
et le tenir sous son charme dans les
bons et mauvais moments
deux mois plus tard ronald reagan
échappe de peu à la mort et personne
mieux que lui n'a raconté l'attentât ce
que les spots publicitaires du parti
républicain montre une amérique heureuse
qui s'enrichit grâce à une politique
ultralibérale à crois qu'il n'y a pas de
laissés pour compte
tout va bien en regani fermement
ce qui se passe dans la basse cour de la
maison blanche
le vilain scandale des armes que l'on a
vendu à l'ennemi iranien pour financer
la guérilla anti communiste au nicaragua
tout cela glisse et affectent bien peu
la popularité commandant temps chez ces
jeunes qui se consacre à son grand
dessein faire chuter l'urss rebaptisé
l'empiré du mal en la contraignant à une
course ruineuse aux armements en 1988
dans un dernier voyage à berlin
et alors qu'il va quitter la maison
blanche ronald reagan à une sorte de
prémonition
ce sera pour l'année suivante et pour le
successeur que le grand communicateur
avait demandé au peuple américain
d'élire son vice président george bush
père ronald reagan célèbre aussi par ses
répliques et son humour a eu un parcours
atypique et tout le monde se souvient
qu'il fut d'abord acteur avant d'entrer
en politique alain de chalvron dans
l'histoire du cinéma ronald regan ne
laissa que quelques lignes aucun des
films dans lesquels la tournée n'est
véritablement passé à la postérité papa
embarrassé d'un bébé chimpanzé officiers
ténébreux
pilote de ligne intrépide ou encore
cowboys bondissant mais toujours
séducteur traqué par des indiens de
pacotille une filmographie de série b
pas toujours des navets mais aucun
chaîneurs l'ancien journaliste sportif
apportant une certaine popularité et son
divorce d'avec l'actrice jane wyman fait
la une des journaux
en fait elle est plus connu que lui et
surtout que la deuxième épouse la
starlette nancy davis où son grand ami
qui deviendra une omniprésente que ce
lundi à la maison blanche avec laquelle
il tourne à quelques publicités pour
l'électricité
faute de récolter les oscars ronald
regan récolte les suffrages de ses
collègues était bien le patron du
syndicat des acteurs anti communiste
convaincu déjà il participe activement à
la chasse aux sorcières du mccarthysme
qui cassera la carrière de tant
d'acteurs de scénaristes ou de metteur
en scène pour ronald reagan cette
période servira de marche-pied politique
jusqu'au poste de gouverneur de
californie où il se fera élire en 1966
14 ans avant d'accéder à la maison
blanche
l'actualité de ce dimanche revenant sur
l'agression d'un adolescent juif à
epinay nous vous le disions hier
plusieurs personnes ont été agressées
dans la nuit qui a suivi un homme
déséquilibré a été arrêté puis relâché
et mis hors de cause yvan martin et
cindy berkous moins de 24 heures après
son interpellation le déséquilibre est
arrêtée hier a été relâché faute de
preuves depuis vendredi à epinay quatre
personnes ont été agressées à l'armé
blanche
deux d'entre elles ont formellement
identifié ce même individu comme leurs
agresseurs
au moment où je sortais de la voiture il
m'a porté
il avait un sac plastique où il y avait
le couteau notamment est
systématiquement il a voulu mais le
porter ses fruits les réflexes j'ai tapé
sur sa mère et là ça m'a touché en pole
ici
là ils m'ont présenté la photo était
catégorique il a dit c'est cette
personne me lis témoins qui ont assisté
à cette scène ne reconnaissent pas ce
portrait quant à israël étudiants juifs
poignardé au thorax vendredi lui non
plus n'identifie pas cet homme comme son
agresseur ses proches le confirmer lé
policiers l'ont présenté des photos de
deux du suspect qui a été arrêté et il
n'a pas repris ou simplement mon coeur
je suis tout de suite que c'était pas le
même qu'il est appelé ce matin en disant
est ce que tu l'as bien reconnue et on
m'a dit non c'est pas lui les policiers
recoupe les témoignages et soumettront
des photos du jeune homme relâche et aux
autres victimes dans les prochaines
heures
ce soir ils n'établissent pas de lien
formel entre ces différentes agressions
et puis cinq gènes dans quatre mineurs
soupçonnés d'avoir agressé il ya une
semaine le fils d'un rabat à boulogne
billancourt
ces jeunes ont été mises en examen et
remises en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire aujourd'hui après avoir été
entendu par le juge d'instruction de
nanterre
huit ans après l'assassinât de la jeune
caroline dickinson dans une auberge de
jeunesse à pleine fougères s'ouvre
demain le procès de son meurtrier
présumé devant la cour d'assises
d'ille-et-vilaine une instruction
particulièrement longue et difficile en
france et à l'étranger
dans le box des accusés un homme
condamné déjà pour plusieurs viols car
une gauthier cet homme à droite c'est
francisco assis montes ce sont les
seules images à ce jour de l'assassin
présumé de caroline dickinson
nous sommes dans un tribunal de floride
en mars 2001 francisco arce et montès
l'ignorent encore
mais dans quelques mois il sera accusé
en france du meurtre de la jeune
britannique
ce 18 juillet 96 au matin caroline
dickinson est retrouvée morte dans sa
chambre au premier étage de l'auberge de
jeunesse de pleine fougères
l'enquète durera cinq ans au départ les
gendarmes n'ont qu'un seul indice la
trace adn laissées par le coupable
alors pour la première fois dans une
telle affaire les enquêteurs utilisent
massivement les tests génétiques tous
les hommes du village de pleine fougères
sont contrôlés en vain
le coupable présumé sera finalement
localisé à miami en 2001 grâce à cet
officier américain tommy ont dit qu
après avoir lu le nom d'art c'est montes
dans un journal mène sa propre enquête
aux états unis avec succès aujourd'hui
huit ans après le drame les parents de
caroline attendent beaucoup de ce procès
sa famille dit quesada besoin de
comprendre ce qui a pu conduire cet
agresseur commettre ces faits là mais
difficile de savoir si francisco arce et
montes acceptera de répondre à toutes
les questions de la famille
c'est quelqu'un qui ait lieu qui
naturellement perturbé qui n'a pas les
idées tout à fait clair et ce qui
complique d'ailleurs également la
préparation la défense demain à
l'audience les défenseurs d'harcèlement
et s vont demander le report du procès
leurs clients risquent la prison à
perpétuité
un mot de politique dans une semaine
donc se dérouleront les élections
européennes on retiendra ce meeting au
zénith à paris cet après midi arlette
laguiller et olivier besancenot font
cause commune pour notre europe nous
espère reproduire leurs scores très
honorables des dernières présidentielles
et puis françois hollande invité de jean
pierre elkabbach sur europe 1 demande à
jacques chirac de tirer toutes les
leçons des élections régionales de mars
et des élections européennes à venir qui
d'après lui ne seront pas meilleures
pour la droite
l'actualité sportive avec cet incroyable
finale à roland garros avec la victoire
tout à fait inattendue de gaston gaudio
qui a battu son compatriote argentin
guillermo coria en cinq sets et victime
de crampes
gilles un moment clé le compte une
victoire à l'usure
gaston gaudio l'homme que personne
n'attendait à ce niveau de la
compétition remporte pour la première
fois de sa carrière
un trophée du grand chelem 27 ans après
guillermo vilas
il est le second argentin s'imposer à
paris et après 3h30 de jeu
gaston gaudio crack mamans mamies et
papys je vous aime je vous ai dit de ne
pas venir mais je pense très fort à vous
vous êtes dans mon coeur toutes et tous
ma famille ma fiancée et pourtant gaston
gaudio face à guillermo coria ici en eau
a d'abord été inexistants dans les deux
premières manches et jusqu'à ce que
coria souffre de crampes
c'est le tournant du match coria laisse
à leur filer les points
gaudio remporté les deux sets suivants
dernière manche les deux argentins
s'accroche
oria aura même deux balles de matches
l'ont transformé qu'audio ne réalise pas
cette erreur victoire en cinq sets
8 6 dans le dernier du coup guèye diop
algues la 44e à la 9e place au
classement mondial et empoche au passage
huit cent soixante mille heures
vt
et tout de suite nous vous retrouvons
daniel bilalian à ouistreham au terme
donc de cette journée de cérémonies
en direct de ouistreham ce soir et bien
les plages sont à nouveau pratiquement
déserte tout au long de 60 kilomètres de
la côte normande où il y à 60 ans a eu
lieu le débarquement du 6 juin les chefs
d'états les chefs de gouvernement les
reines les différents personnalités sont
repartis et j'allais dire ceux qui ont
combattu ce jour là se retrouvent seuls
avec leur mémoire
si ces festivités du 60e anniversaire du
débarquement obtenu un tel succès c'est
peut-être que malheureusement
malheureusement pour la dernière fois
bon nombre de vétérans étaient sur place
ne seront pas là peut-être pour le 70e
espérons-le pour le 80e anniversaire de
ce débarquement et donc ils ont voulu
transmettre ce message ce message de
liberté qu'ils avaient vécu ce 6 juin
et vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
sur la plage d'omaha beach et bien il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes venus d'une
certaine façon s'instruire aujourd'hui
reportage loïc de la mornais jean-marie
lequertier au bruit des tanks les
motards ont préféré le son de leurs
harley cet après midi en l'absence de
grandes commémorations officielles
l'ambiance à omaha beach était
décontractée mais pas - recueilli par
tous les manifestation improvisée pour
les vétérans et pour que la mémoire ne
se perdent pas au fil des générations
les enfants sont clairement impliqué
j'aime bien ton drapeau américain
pourquoi tu l'aimais bien
enfin les demandes hitler même si ça
nous avons les emmener au cimetière
américain on leur a expliqué que c'était
des gens que tu es parti au ciel et
toulon qu'ils étaient surpris dit tous
ces gens là sont partis aussi jouer ils
sont d'une sauver donc on leur explique
avec des mots simples et au milieu d'une
ambiance carrosserie on voit également
d'émouvantes scène de dédicaces regardez
ce qu'il m'a écrit nous n'avons pas
gagné cette guerre nous avons juste
permis de la finir plus vite
ici tout le monde rigole s'amuse mais
ces gars sont tombés ils sont mort pour
nous sur la plage baigneurs du dimanche
ces familles de vétérans partage ce
sable désormais si célèbre ici à cette
heure ci c'était l'enfer il y avait des
morts il y avait des choses
épouvantables et aujourd'hui fait beau
l'american les gens se baignent et la
vie a repris et grâce à eux on peut dire
à ce sacrifice
les vétérans repartent certains d'entre
eux ne reverront plus omar
mais la commémoration ne sera sans doute
jamais sur cette plage où le cours de
l'histoire se mêle au cours de la vie
toute une série de cérémonies ont eu
lieu au tout au long de cet après midi
nous en avons déjà rendu compte
la dernière en date elle s'est déroulée
ici même à quelques mètres d'ici à ce
monument
ce monument à la mémoire des anciens du
commando qui est faire c'est 177
français les seuls les sols du
débarquement le 6 juin 44 auquel le chef
de l'état monsieur jacques chirac en
compagnie du premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin a voulu aujourd'hui
rendre hommage il avait été dix ans pour
un certain nombre un peu oublié ces 60
dernières années
ces hommes du commando kieffer avait
débarqué ici avec les anglo américains
les canadiens 150 mille hommes au total
avaient débarqué tout au long de cette
journée
le débarquement a commencé à 6h30 du
matin
voyons l'état des forces l'état des
combats tel qu'il se présentait le soir
du 6 juin 44 aux alentours de 20h30
nicolas chateauneuf en cette soirée du 6
juin
les généraux alliés respire la première
phase du débarquement de normandie est
une réussite et les hommes fait
l'événement
à leur manière
cent cinquante six mille soldats ont
pris pied sur le sol français sur les
plages rennes une intense activité 1400
tonnes de matériel sont déchargées vingt
mille véhicules dont 900 chars sont déjà
prêts au combat
l'immense défi logistique de l'opération
overlord est en passe d'être remporté la
1re manche le port artificiel est en
cours d'assemblage pour accélérer
l'arrivée des renforts
toute la journée les combats ont été
acharnés en particulier sur roma francs
secteur américain home à la sanglante à
cet endroit les bombardements alliés ont
manqué leur cible
la garnison allemande et plus aguerris
et deux fois plus nombreuses que prévu
à 6h30 du matin les premières vagues
d'assaut ce fonds décimé en quelques
heures plus de 2000 soldats meurent sur
ses plages
mais grâce au courage de quelques hommes
les défenses finissent par se fissurer
et en fin de soirée la situation reste
précaire
mais les allemands ont reculé
ailleurs les troupes progressent à
l'intérieur des terres mais se heurte à
une vive résistance aux alentours de
quand les généraux alliés avaient prévu
de prendre la ville dès le jour j les
camps ne sera libéré que deux mois plus
tard
entre temps le commandement allemand
s'est ressaisie y autorise enfin
l'emploi des blindés la 21e division de
panzers contre attaque met en ordre
dispersé
profitant d'une brèche entre
britanniques et canadiens ces éléments
les plus avancés pousseront même
jusqu'aux plages où ils découvriront les
barges de débarquement que les alliés
ont laissé derrière eux mais l'avant
sera de courte durée car dans le ciel
l'aviation alliée est partout et la
luftwaffe invisible les convois et les
troubles en mouvement sont harcelés
les quelques blindés allemands qui en
réchappent doivent se replier
le combat va dorénavant se jouer à
l'intérieur des terres dans le bocage
normand
chaque village chaque être chaque roue
devient une bataille en soi
en mer les premiers blessés sont
entassés à bord des navires hôpitaux les
antennes médicales sont débordés en
moins de 24 heures près de dix mille
soldats alliés ont été tués blessés ou
portés disparus
pour l'état-major c'est moins que prévu
mais pour ces jeunes soldats ce sont des
frères d'armes que l'on ne reverra plus
au soir du 6 juin 1944 vous l'avez
entendu sur les 60 kilomètres de plages
du débarquement et bien les alliées ont
pris position sur environ 10 kg 2 km à
l'intérieur du pays de la france déjà
celle là libérer ce débarquement du 6
juin 44 c'est une fantastique aventure
humaine avec vous l'avez entendu pour la
seule plage d'omaha beach 2000
américains qui sont morts au combat
on comptera à la fin de cette journée
environ dix mille soldats morts blessés
ou disparus
c'est une fantastique aventure humaine
c'est aussi une fantastique aventure
technique en même temps que les soldats
alliés débarqué sur les plages de
normandie en direction d'un roman je
dirigeais un pan artificielle qui avait
été construit pièce par pièce sur la
côte normande et qui arrivait qu'ils
commençaient d'arriver
ce soir là pour alimenter les troupes
alliées qui avait débarqué le matin même
yannick notamment comment ces blocs de
béton de 6000 tonnes
ont-ils pu être construits dans le plus
grand secret flotter et traverser la
manche pour former ici ce qui fut le
plus grand port du monde
à cette question winston churchill n'a
donné qu'un ordre
trouvez moi la meilleure des solutions
ne me parlez pas des problèmes 1943 le
problème c'est que les alliés n'ont pas
de porc ou débarquer vivre munitions et
matérielles alors ce port ils la
porteront dans leurs bagages pendant
huit mois aux quatre coins de
l'angleterre
les 500 pièces d'un gigantesque meccano
sont fabriqués le projet et si
éparpillés que personne ne se rend
compte de son but final la nuit des sous
marins de poche viennent récupérer des
échantillons de sable sur la plage
d'arromanches tandis qu'est lancé un
autre projet peut être le plus secret
d'entre tous le projet plutôt la pose
d'un pipeline sous la manche pour
ravitailler en essence des troupes du
débarquement
dès le 6 juin les caissons sont tractés
par des remorqueurs puis coulé sur le
sable c'est le squelette du futur porte
arromanches de vieux rafiot cool et
serviront de brise-lames les questions
deviennent des quais auquel on relit
déroute flottante de 1200 mètres de long
l'ensemble forme une rade de 8 km les
plates formes ont été construits
avec + coulissant qu'on descendait au
fond de la mer qui ancrait la plateforme
et la plateforme ouvert monter et
descendre en fonction des marées cette
plateforme était relié à louxor
qui arrivent elles à la cour et donc le
port était opérationnel 24 heures sur 24
c'est à dire que les maintenant prouver
et chargé à tout moment de jour ou de
nuit marée haute ou marraine voici ce
qui reste aujourd'hui de cette ville
flottante de 30000 hommes véritables
défis techniques et financiers ont dit
que ce port unique dans l'histoire a
représenté l'équivalent du programme
apollo sur la lune
à quelques kilomètres à peine de ce port
artificiel d'arromanches khune doit en
détailler bien il ya la plage d'omaha
beach ce fut là les combats les plus
sanglants de ce débarquement les
américains débarquèrent les allemands
les attendaient de pied ferme
et je vous le disais il ya quelques
instants on comptait ce soir-là 2000
morts parmi les soldats américains
alors cette plage d'omaha beach et bien
elle a vu également débarquer en dehors
des commandos qui est fair qui ont
débarqué sur cette plage ici de
ouistreham elle a vu débarquer un
français le soldat ollivro qui avaient
pris place parmi les premiers débarquant
les premiers soldats américains qui
débarquait des badges des barges sur la
plage d'omaha beach
il était 6h30 ce matin du 6 juin 1944 au
portage de ces cinq années de guerre
il a conservé une démarche plutôt
militaire à 79 ans jacques ollivro coule
une paisible retraite au bord de la
marne
même si chaque jour et chaque nuit il
revit ce terrible mardi matin du 6 juin
sur la plage d'omaha
on est arrivé à marée basse les ja et on
a essuyé un feu intense mais très très
intense et une véritable boucherie
on n'avait aucune défense aucune
protection
il n'y avait pas un art n'y avait pas un
rocher avait pas de sable
j'ai voulu un moment m'abriter derrière
un cheval le free je vous ai j'entendais
sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt sa mort
donnée dans la tête
le soldat ollivro avait alors 19 ans et
il est probablement l'unique français
d'omar le seul à avoir débarqué sous
l'uniforme américain de la célèbre big
red one la première division
d'infanterie us
le jour j entre colleville et saint
laurent et voici pourquoi
en avril 1944 le soldat ollivro est ici
en angleterre
arrivant du maroc dans les rangs de la
2e db du général leclerc
un jour un officier de la france libre
cherche un volontaire qui parle allemand
pour devenir soldat de liaison des
américains j'ai donc accepté la
proposition parce que je parlais un
allemand n'ont pas littéraire mais un
allemand de cuisine est effectivement
scheer rejoint ce groupe qui est terres
qui appartenaient l'ati au 18e régiment
d'infanterie
la première division la première armée
américaine sous l'uniforme des marines
avec le un sur l'épaule gauche
le soldat ollivro devient jack pour ses
copains de péniches il embarque le 5
juin vers la normandie cac ne parle pas
un mot d'anglais
ce n'est pas un problème nombre de ses
boys sont d'origine allemand beaucoup
sont israélite et ont fui le régime nazi
pour émigrer aux états unis dès les
années 30 ils seront les premiers à
s'engager
jack lui a le mérite de parler le
français pour les premiers contacts avec
la population normande et l'allemand
pour conduire les interrogatoires des
futurs prisonniers de la wehrmacht
la fonction c'était surtout d'arriver le
premier avec mémé mais quelques bonnes
âmes pour choper les prisonniers en
premier obtenir des renseignements en
priorité d'où viens tu quelle compagnie
quel régiment vous avez des armes
lourdes vous avez des blindés que l'on
communiqué après aux troupes qui était
derrière deux mois après le débarquement
le soldat ollivro réintègre la 2e db du
général leclerc
il participe le 26 août à l'autre ou
grands événements de sa vie
la libération de paris
démobilisé en 1946 avec le grade de
caporal chef
jacques ollivro passera le reste de sa
vie à vendre des fleurs pour mieux
oublier la guerre au soir de ce 60e
anniversaire du débarquement il me
revient la phrase d'un général américain
dont j'ai perdu le nom et qui disait
essayons que nos vies soient dignes de
ces héros qui sont morts aujourd'hui
pour la liberté
parmi les vétérans qui étaient présents
ce matin ici sur la plage de ouistreham
un anglais sans doute le corps ne visiez
le plus célèbre de l'armée britannique
vous le connaissez sûrement puisque vous
avez vu ce film fantastique le jour le
plus long
il était à la tête d'un groupe de
soldats anglais qui avait pour mission
de prendre le pont de pegasus sur la
route de caen il avait avec lui sa
cornemuse c'était sa seule arme ce matin
et bien je les croisais par hasard et je
vous propose de revivre avec lui
quelques minutes d'émotion son nom bil
bil in
c'est peut-être bien
c'est donc se termine ce journal je
remercie de votre attention tout de
suite aimé qu isabelle martinez 20h55
d'idées leur jour le plus long
un film documentaire de richard d'elle
une artiste dires du journal jean todt
renault 13 heures daniel bilalian david
depuis j'attends à 20h et demain soir
mots croisés présentée par arlette
chabot avec ce débat au soir du 60e
anniversaire de la libération de
l'europe et ce au nom des mêmes valeurs
que les états unis sont intervenus en
irak
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2 ce
soir sur france 2 dit dès le dock
événement le film des histoires vraies
de ceux qui ont fuit le jour j ensuite
palace roland garros au tour de france
c'est en coulisses que ça se passe à
france 2 dix des leurs jours le plus
long les coulisses du pouvoir
et pour ceux qui auraient manqué le
direct revivez dans la nuit la finale
hommes de roland garros en intégralité
bonne soirée sur france 2 l'image du
jour sur france 2 avec peugeot